personne n'a crié dans cette maison et
pourtant nous devons aller à la voile à
trois noms oui bravo gym y aller tu es
je viens d'arriver je suis seul au monde
c'est totalement désert mais où êtes
vous en fait personne n'est venu c'est
ça moi il fait une grosse blague
la vidéo ch'ti ça n'existe pas j'ai plus
qu'à me téléporter pour rentrer chez moi
et porte ainsi à ça pas marché du tout
je ne reste pas souvient tous du tube
heures au quai et ses angles alliance à
mieux s'amuse comme on peut
et il est vrai qu actuellement j'attends
d'aller sur le stand de dédicaces ma vie
est nul un vrai choix entre un troll et
je passe dans vingt ou trente minutes à
bron voir et j'ai hâte
voilà je suis entre des murs blancs de
part en part et ça n'a rien d'amusant
voilà enfin arrivé sur mon stand avec un
max de gens allez je vous montrais ya
des gens partout
oh
e
d'accord avec ce n'est vraiment pas une
blague y avoir beaucoup de gens et j'ai
un petit établissement de stylos billes
juste ici on peut voir effectivement je
veux faire couler énormément grand
jamais vu autant de quatre couleurs dans
si peu d espace ça va être chouette a
offert un cadeau je veux rire maintenant
au hulk
merci beaucoup et un deuxième cadeau
encore mieux un cou de girafe pas mais
va aussi offert attention un cadeau
incroyable
un d'alter femina pour avoir un
mac de vidéos ma elle y est ce elle est
très bas sur le d'accord je suis une
merde
celle d'être une mère de cette femme
bien avec un kilo de cadeaux c'est son
ordinaire go aux c'est génial
hier ce super dessin et à côté ya un
rondoudou on sait pas pourquoi je suis
avec air coûte en fait son nom
comme ceci eh ben j'ai cru que ça
voulait dire coupe de cheveux en anglais
et à corte
bon ça la fait rire mais moyennement
voilà il ya des gens qui ont aidé
cassure des papiers blancs comme ça et
d'autres petits mots donne ça qui a
envie de signer là dessus bertone
personnes on vient de me remettre la
récompense ultime
voilà je suis diplômé la virilité qui
suit affaires bâtard décerné à squeeze
c'est un diplôme officiel mon gars comme
le bac le trophée youtube
quand tu as atteint les 100 abonnés
fabrique 1
partager
ouais on voit le bon bout et c'est un
cadeau pour je mange je te déteste
l'homme au plus tard acharnant qu on
arrive à la fin c'est l'une des
dernières
quoi non je prédis blague
moque de moi c'est quoi je pense mais
son fatal sous le bureau tu as gagné
voilà la minul il ya plus personne n'en
a que c'est la dernière personne c'est
incroyable
ça va bien plus personne n'est là les
gens là bas qui roulait perdu 15 kg
voilà
à la place c'est super ça va faire un
curé le heureusement
il est passé très près je vis du futur
ça reste qu'il a le pressing maintenant
la rupture de l'est voilà et c'est la
fin je suis maintenant tout seul c'est
abusé je vous avais jamais vu si
nombreux et où c'est incroyable c'est
très émouvant
huberdeau robot
je suis cacher je veux rester là vingt
minutes je sais trop bien les gens là
évidemment disparition maixent blague
alors garde est puceau pour la première
fois on va passer on est ton dur tu vas
nous résister semaines le téléthon de
muscles celui de tibhrine chez son fils
homo à nantes
il est toute une semaine s'il soulève de
la frontex était tout aussi bon je veux
dire que j'avais raison petacchi fait
d'accord ça prend des tournures
inattendues ensemble ok donc là gros bad
je viens de perdre mes clés tout
simplement elles sont peut-être déjà là
oh j'ai retrouvé je suis super le
cupcake
mais on dirait un peu dé beir tellement
ça fait 3 heures que j'attends dans cet
espace j'ai pas s'il veut survivre mais
voir un mec qu'on jamie bell go voilà on
s'occupe comme on peut hein je sais que
vous aurez pas me le dire mais avouez
que je suis plus musclée que lui
envoient le personnage de dire mais
c'est dans la nuque
actuellement elle est sur scène pour
remettre les trophées un million
d'abonnés vous savez les cadres et que
vous tourner totalement bing bing
on va les remettre le rouge en sept
couleurs les déplacements sont un peu
compliquées bonjour je ne savais pas
c'est qu'on est d'espionner autant
trouver où sont les espérances
les ai pas trouvés vous les avez pas
trouvé ses pairs du avait une veste
verte a gagné il était là bas l'abus
total ça fait maintenant quinze minutes
rien
m
meiway au jeu
quand je dis hébronites grannec quand je
débranche petit fils
quand j'ai brosseau a dit jean-louis
annonçant jeudi branche rodix benamram y
penser orosdi brody
que j'aime
outre tenu à canon quand je dis si prix
l'impôt dit ça on dit rien on dit rien
de ce qui arrive quand ça ne tourne pas
bien ça gueule derrière ces principes de
mon prénom c'est par ici
voilà château bien comprendre c'est
excellent monier enfin prétendent
attentes
ouais
cérémonie pour m c'est pas du cadre
c'est bon pour l'image mais c'est très
pratique pour les gens
moi j'aime bien les batteurs et du
grillage et gens qui savent faire ça
oh
ces données sont là c'est la joie des
joueurs dont il voudrait on appris apa
la chanson norman en live et c'est fini
je rentre chez moi vous repère des
vidéos de magie opère encore de vidéo
elle induit aussi et mardi j'ai bien que
mardi vidéo d'accord je fais quoi
maintenant la vidéo d'accord maintenant
je dis je fais quoi aux mondiaux a pas
monté sur sajoo vous présenter mon crew
ils vont pas tarder à arriver c'est des
mecs qui savent rien faire dans la vie
les coaches ils sont arrivés pour notre
prestation hors du commun sur scène la
salsa le templier ces partis attention à
l'étroit sur nul à celle autour de la
moustache qui gratte
oui charge pour que les bus s'appuie
comme un moine
sur ton canapé on voit ton poker on ne
prend pas trop tout sans make parce qu'à
banias les pompiers qui par ce que tu
veux te suicider
je suis toujours vivant
l'homme qui transpire le plus au monde
parce que moi je trouvais l'euro mais
voilà on a fait le 5 janvier en live
c'est super c'était chaud doux très
agréable et acier moins grave c'est la
seule dans ce salon
attention on se retrouve dans un instant
l'endroit aucun acte l'énergie je suis
sur le départ
pendant cinq minutes et on m'a offert un
sac rempli d'un trésor inouïe des têtes
brûlées par tous
est-ce que cela pique toujours oui le
café de fin de journée pour survivre si
cet homme près de dix fois ma taille
wars iii s'ébattre mais par contre ce
qu'il sait pas c'est qu'on n'est jamais
à l'abri d'un poste était et bouma voici
un cadeau incroyable c'est un véritable
livre sur nous ces deux personnes qui
ont fait ça c'est vraiment retrace plein
de deux moments
j'arrive plus à parler je trop fatigué
au revoir et est l'heure de rentrer à la
maison je suis lyncher je peux finir la
phrase te plait je suis lyncher
et
l'un chez l'autre écoutez maintenant on
est entre nous je voulais faire le petit
bilan en rentrant chez moi mais je me
dis que c'est pas une mauvaise idée de
faire ici à chaud comme ça et tout
c'était hyper touchant de tout savoir
sur ce salon vous m'avez offert plein de
cadeaux plein de sourires et de bonne
heure et c'est ça qui était assez ouf ça
va vraiment beaucoup touché je sais
qu'un a plein qui n'ont pas pu avoir de
dédicaces ou de ou de moments passés
avec moi mais honnêtement vous êtes
énormément dans mon coeur voilà je suis
vraiment en bonne santé mentale on peut
le dire les violons absolument la
musique romantique mais c'était vraiment
très touchant je me suis battu et la
voix d'ange et par les six mois d'avril
grandes gueules c'était plus tard il
perd tout changer même pas les mots pour
vous décrire dans l'huma vmu aujourd'hui
et ce qui est fou c'est qu'on remet ça
totalement demain j'espère assuré je
suis rentré dormir immédiatement pour
demain assuré encore une fois parce que
là la fatigue est présent merci à tous
d'être
une prochaine vidéo city à la blague je
te montre vif